je remercie pour l'instant je vous
propose de regarder dans quelle préparé
par henriette chardac sur le mariage
précisément entre plusieurs radios le
mariage entre fréquence gaie carole fm
et ne va commencer le co existence est
possible sur la bande fm 150 radios ce
pirate est les ondes en septembre après
les mariages forcés ou les mariages
d'amour de l'été des stations enfin
audible
cette grosse fréquence une note moyenne
et une de quartier mariage de raison
entre les radios confessionnelles
mariage contre nature avec la radio
sauvé in extremis fréquence gaie la
radio des homosexuels on est une grande
famille et je vous dis pour nous on
parle d'invitation et non de mariage et
comme une invitation un bal en cirant on
ne s'y rend par faisaient donc sa radio
de france vous deviez vous marier avec
carole fm alors ce mariage afin lieu
pourquoi d'abord de la part de bon c'est
simple c'est un peu dur pour faire les
faits parce qu'il est évident qu'on a
rien à rien à faire ensemble ils s'en
sont très vite rendus compte même avant
toute négociation possible ils ont
décidé en conseil d'administration au
sein de leur radio que c'était même pas
la peine de rentrer en contact avec nous
on était vraiment
une communauté bien spécifiques
oui pas de mariage avec fréquence quai
pour la simple et bonne raison que
fréquent guerre de nous obtenu donc
cette fréquence à part entière dans les
petites fréquence et qu'il est hors de
question qu'on se marie avec une
gestation qui a donc son identité propre
tout de suite après soft cell samoura du
pionir carreau les femmes bien avant le
10 mai dont les problèmes avant le 10
mai nous avons des problèmes maintenant
je crois qu'il est indispensable pour
qu'une station ville pour que ces 45
personnes travaillent dans des façons
efficaces et d'un dans les façon
confortable c'est avoir des moyens et
ses moyens on les veut tout de suite à
dire donc une fréquence tout de suite
j'ai l'impression qu'en fait que travail
de la commission l'eau at-il tout
simplement de faire un travail des
agences matrimoniales
cette nouvelle union entre 19 ans ivre
se fait autour d'un thème qui est celui
de la création je crois que l'équipe de
nova est bien placé par rapport à ça
pour défendre une radio de création
maintenant pour ce qui est des
programmes à venir il y aura une
première phase qui sera une phase
d'apprentissage d'une équipe par rapport
à l'autre et puis se dessinera une
nouvelle politique de programmes dont
nora ne va aura aura la charge
il faut distinguer entre les mariages
qui ont été fait de gaieté de coeur ou
deux dans des stratégies bien pensés
comme c'est notre cas où mariage qui ont
été imposées soit par la commission sa
part des stratégies de dernière minute
et le temps de nous allons être une des
sept grosses fréquence de la région
parisienne d'abord nous allons en finir
avec notre système des coudes
confidentiel du fait qu'ils avaient
beaucoup trop d'amateurs autour de nous
de parasitage des radios les unes sur
les autres et qu'on va enfin pouvoir de
la manière la plus légale s'organiser de
manière à toucher le plus large
auditoire possible
nous avons donc pu citer computer aisé
de l'espace 1901 qui sera la radio
spécialistes des sujets hyper chiant
comme l'économie aurait social univers
solaire d'afrique pilipili destiné aux
immigrés et où pilipili paris nous par
aspect qu'en sport musique et lecture
une radio de service qui proposera
notamment du sport de la musique et de
la lecture
tous les fans et de 13,1 faut les gagner
mais ça je vous signale que c'est
formellement interdit par la loi mais
line de cette dérogation
c'est le cas de tana hyacinthe où se
retrouvent toutes un serrage sur les
bras les nanas radieuse le temps des
cerises et par sud c'est beaucoup pour
un seul homme mariages fictifs possible
enfin c'est carrément marier avec
vocation et diapason qui sont des envies
et de ses fantasmes
ils ne savaient même pas qu'ils allaient
fouiller c'est par exemple le cas de
miss caroil fm rentrer tranquillement se
coucher elle a trouvé un mec sous le
paillasson
monsieur métropolis qui lui a dit trois
doses carole suis ton mari la team doit
obéissance